[Music]
let's open with that that was good no no
don't open with that that was perfect
you heard that Rose Bud yes thank you
for having me thanks for doing it man
good to have you love to love being here
I know you're a busy guy not really but
uh well you know I I you work a lot and
then there's lots of hours of not
working yeah that's you know that's what
we all do I think that's ideal that's
how I like it I like to go hard and then
is really veg out right get a water
burger and a and a nice steak that's
right you eat highend we do we do well
uh we do decently well we were at the
stand last night lot of hospitality
there oh my God the they put everything
out for us you know uh my agent is also
a man of size and um Justin yes and he
got fatter he's big and then the he I
remember we were all free agents at the
same time during we were all agentless
and and I remember taking a walk with
him and he was not big then no it co uh
really brought out people's
passions whether it's fanol or pizza
right I like dressing dogs yeah whatever
you were into just during Co it really
went nuclear and I think he's having
some success some guys get a nice suit
in a car some guys get fatter he's doing
great he's got a hot wife really yes
wife's gorgeous I don't believe it I
believe I'm telling you H pull her
up
and uh he's doing good his people are
doing good um uh you know and and I so I
think he's you know a happy man and
Chris was very nice to send everything
out and I mean he should have pizza
after was crazy we were calling Comics
over just please these open micers they
haven't eaten in weeks it was like
PTZ they all left they were like thank
you thank you it was great you don't how
many kids or not kids but younger Comics
text me like that was amazing hanging
out with you guys it was nice no it was
fun that's what the festival is about is
like people just hanging out and
remember they used to do that big
Caroline's party the uh where they do
the free food and everything that that
was a big party you want to talk about
someone who looks great by the way is
Caroline she looks still you guil alert
yeah I saw her out east got to be late
60s she's looks stunning that's
ridiculous she looks great wow yeah
she's like a sopia she was at my show
Saturday I was like is that hot whether
they are women or men will they all like
look kind of like Patrick Milligan
whether they're women or men they just
kind of mold into that eventually it's
their final form right their final form
they just get there it might take a
while this very but they get there
eventually and Caroline just looks like
a like just a hot yeah well she was
smart enough to close it you know she's
like I'm done with this hole and
I'm done with that what was that gay guy
who had the little dog yes you were
setting me up
here uh yeah L fanda was a CL
literally would walk up to every with an
earshot every comic you're the best
comic in town kid I'd see him walk up to
Joe Mackey you kid you're number one
every go up to a homeless guy outside
you got the goods my
friend it would just blow smoke but I I
needed that energy at that time two
years ago um we were thinking of doing
the Apollo Theater by the way in the
height of like the George me and it was
like the worst idea like my agent called
me goes how about this cuz he probably
want to have chicken and waffles so he
goes how about this we have the Apollo
Theater on hold for the festival I go oh
man this doesn't seem like a great idea
right like it seems like the worst idea
ever it's like me in the Apollo Theater
I think in like 2021 oh it was just like
and I think Louis fanda to his credit
was like we're not doing
this he's like we're not doing that at
all that's the real problem he's doing
he's doing the Iron Dome
[Laughter]
the we get a lot of mileage out of that
one have you done comedy in Israel I was
supposed to do it in April I know I'm
still going I got a good feel you'll
still do it'll be good by April come on
you're in it's winding down it's coming
down yeah you're fine I just go by uh
tweets so I don't know what's happening
on the ground even worse it's hard to
sustain you can't sustain remember
Ukraine in the beginning you know
they're singing ASN now there's folks
songs and people are like you can't I
mean I really thought uh Hillary doing
Hallelujah that that was going to turn
it around that was that was
brutal I love I love Leonard con I'm
like this is how you honor him I thought
it was the last I thought it was the
last thing of that and I I thought I was
totally okay with it I'm like oh it's a
postmortem okay and then you woke up the
next day and it was like more of it yeah
and they're like no it's Hallelujah
forever you're like no no no we have to
I you get like one I thought what Pete
did was fine I was like that's like a
sincere moment that's like a tough
monologue that
that was good but yeah it's hard but uh
and he does have experience you know
with the whole
thing he does it's a tough you know it's
a tough thing to go out there that week
and go hey but remember the old SNL
remember after 911 happened Rudy
Giuliani hosted he was like what'd he
say can we be funny or no Lauren
somebody why start now
Rudy that was funny he used to dress in
drag on SNL didn't he do a bit in drag
jul I'm almost positive with Trump pull
it up with Trump I mean this is how
crazy the country's gotten now where you
know that was funny back then everybody
was laughing yeah yeah and now it's all
splintered you know yeah 2003 Osama Bin
Laden hosted that was hilarious it was
great he was good he was a good host he
bombed all
right that's a very different
speech fun I ever tell you that I went
to I went to like a summer camp with
Rudy giuliani's uh son when I was like
uh he tried to kill me he tried to
ground me it was yeah we were like kind
of cool for like the first few minutes
and then I think I called him fat or
something I said something shitty and he
and he held my head underwater he like
he was a strong kid you look him
up he's listen to me that's you're just
explaining Israel and Palestine I mean
it's you were both in the wrong he had a
little size on you but everybody kind of
learned their lesson right he the
American government on his side yeah had
a couple more billion you know I had
these eyebrows yeah for sure it was
complicated but there's Andrew Giuliani
and I believe Chris Farley played Andrew
juliani skit one killed it really yes I
miss that it's hilarious Andrew
Giuliani is a a typical
sociopath politician son like if you see
the eyes like there's eyes that you just
can't God Farley was man Kevin
nean too unbelievable cast it was
amazing it was a hot show remember you
look forward to this you ran home a
braver better
future yeah he looks like Andy Rooney in
Breakfast at Tiffany's I guess Angel is
joining me here
today differences
aside I was the Law and Order candidate
but today I'm the people's mayor well my
grandfather came here with $20 in his
pocket I mean it's one joke and he's
playing Amazing commit dude when he does
nude kingri when he he goes to the uh
Congress and Farley does new gingr in
front of new gingr in all it's amazing
never seen that yeah he does new Grid in
the capital rotunda it's crazy and it's
just like you have everybody there oh I
have seen this it's yeah it's amazing
it's just like he just oozes funny he
can't he just oozes funny like whatever
he does wherever he goes even even his
movies at missed they still funny Almost
Heroes is a funny movie yeah Beverly
Hill ninja yeah Beverly hill ninjas
look at this this is already funny I'm
dying it's amazing the white hair it's
so fat it's
great n n n imagine killing there that's
the hardest room in the world there's no
harder room we play the danger field for
Ronald Reagan bit oh I mean just
annihilate annihilating and it's like
it's kind of amazing it's amazing what a
hell gig huge turnout my God thank you
this is great this
is here uh I'm reading a few new books
right now uh you might want to be
interested uh got Daniel Steel's ches a
great new book and uh Jackie Collins
husband Hollywood
husbands very interesting book they all
standing my my new dinosaur book so uh
see you could never do this now with
Biden they wouldn't let you do it which
is which is sad let us be funny cpan and
of course my friends at PBS
also for those of you watching the uh NE
open your textbook I think he starts
like passing legislation oh fun they
have a great is a clip
ofy Lang describing what it was like to
roast Donald Trump and it's
Arty Lang it was on Seth Meers I
think but he's just talking about he's
like you know we're roasting him and and
and we're talking about on Howard Stern
and and Trump is like you're you were
the best you had the set of the night
and then Arty tells one of the jokes
goes He bombed he was terrible he bombed
he wasn't funny perfect he just can't
hand he just can't handle it at all it's
yeah now it would be tough to to roast
like to get everybody together oh yeah
and really like I guess a White House
corresponding is the closest thing but
like you know even then that seems to be
on eggshells more than it was right you
got to play ball like that was the
Republican committee your agent would go
don't it's Republican don't do it do it
but it's still a cool
so but it's your country I think it's I
mean the way Norman used to do it the
way did it back in the day I mean they
it's it's cool to to find a you a way to
bring it together I don't know yeah what
comedy is and that's when you see it in
its purest form like that where it just
it leaves a comedy club leaves a theater
and it's just raw in the world right and
you put it in the world like Uso tours
are amazing CU you're like you're in
front of like servicemen who are like
desperate for entertainment they're out
there they're they're some of their
friends are dying it's like an amazing
environment and you're bringing them
entertainment you know and and everyone
talks about how great those shows are
everybody I've never done them but
everyone goes like they're amazing shows
everything like that and it's amazing
anything political no one ever says that
like nobody's ever like this is going to
be great right this will be so much fun
it's at the Bethesda Country Club in
Maryland no you're going to love it
love it it's the teachers union and you
are going to it's people who need comedy
versus people who are inconvenienced by
your presents right that's really is I
remember I did I did a wounded warriors
thing on a New Year's one year and it
was the best New Year's gig I've ever
done they laugh at everything
yeah atel is really like the master of
those gigs because he just know he's
like nothing political just dick jokes
silly you know everybody laugh I bombed
it hard at one of those and I was like
this crowd's ungettable they're the wor
way out in the Hampton
Country Club Super Rich they hated me
Voss went up after me and I was like
good luck they're worthless he gets on
the stool and he's like what's wrong
with your face to some lady and it's
murdering and he just keeps hammering
them you look at you you got your money
you're only blowing him cuz he's Rich
all this and it was gold and I was
like all right that that was a lesson
it's like when a street fighter just
like knocks out a boxer that's he's
he's just so good Quinn called
him the master of the counter punch
that's what he is you Barbara Bush
looking you know just spitting
everywhere killing no it's I've seen him
we did I opened for him he did an AA
special which has still not been
released which is amazing interesting
and he did it in like the
Huntington Melville
Marriott Long Island like the Huntington
Hilton and he just murdered and it's
just you know an AA group and they're in
there and they're all sitting in chairs
and it's like and he just again
murdering going through the crowd like
one by one like boom boom boom aa's
great crowd AA cops firemen all great
crowds and Voss has done those gigs for
years I remember when we did that
Joker's Cruise remember that yes after
one of the shows one of the gigs I was
on one was with Voss and some lady walks
up to me and she goes you are our
favorite and Voss goes oh yeah well your
other friends are prettier than you I
was like Oh my he was so funny
we get stranded at the airport after the
gig it was like he had status with
United or something he gets on he's
complaining for like 40 minutes straight
he gets on a flight in an hour I'm there
for 7even hours it was a horrible day
but some guy
like insults Voss and Voss just turns to
him and and just goes look at your
face and just starts destroying
this guy like a crowd gathered around
and I can only imagine what's going
through a person's head Voss is like
biblical it's like like there's like
he's like a guy who's always ready to
like unleash a prophecy at in the
direction of another person who's wrong
him he's always ready to just pivot and
just start laying into somebody and the
best is at the airport he even opened
his suitcase and sold CDs
also you have Bonnie who's also amazing
and quick and sharp so those fights have
to be like most entertaining things
you've ever seen kids get a front row
seat right it's just I mean the bars
right yeah that's true yeah those gigs
those gigs are uh they're kind of over
like have you done one of those in a
while uh like a like a rehab gig I have
not I just losted out on I was supposed
to do a fundraiser tonight for Joe Tori
the Yankees former man and I lost out on
it Joe tor messaged my agent and
was like I love his stuff I'd love to
have him on the show I I see my agent on
Saturday I'm like so what you didn't
send me the details for this Joe Tory
gig I can't wait and he goes you lost
the gig I was like how he goes his wife
hated
you what a what an up and that's
comedy is like I know I lost I lost a
benefit gig I'm not even getting
paid for this I was going there just to
be like I get to meet Joe Tory but she's
never met you I know but she saw some CL
I I just wanted to know the clip that
upset her I want to know too any clip
any clip probably the one where you call
women
[Laughter]
retards oh yeah it's also was probably
her like she probably watched it and
like she probably was like this is a
good opportunity to exert my will he
exactly you know exactly he's got his
dumb Yankees and all his that he
does let me you know like show that I
can flexx I have power I hate to
comedian I had the same thing I did a
corporate gig in Philly Ballroom nice
hotel they could put me out in a limo
they bought me a tuxedo the whole thing
crazy money I had to host the
pharmaceutical awards that was the whole
gig so I have I'm up there for like
three hours with cards and like give it
up for Zoloft and it's table you
know it's a round table so the three
it's three hours I memorized I had
PowerPoints it was music cues it was a
whole like a Oscars for pharmaceutical
drugs and this I'm doing my first 15
minutes clean up front I did one joke
about vibrators the lady comes up to me
with the head thing you know and the
clipboard and she's like you're out I'm
like what she's like the wife got mad
the head's wife got mad I'm like I came
here to limbo we got two and a two hours
and 45 minutes to go she's like yeah
Bob's going to do it I was like all
right and they sent me home paid you I
got paid all right but it was all
because the wife got offended by a
vibrator joke it's always the wife yeah
well it's always like a tough like I did
a fundraiser in Long Island it was a a
cancer thing like I had no idea what it
was they booked me and they were
honoring a a a young girl who had passed
away and they had a a lot of music and
they figured we all get a comedian yeah
and they were just do it was this
fundraiser that raises money for people
with cancer and it wasn't like about
specifically this girl but like her
mother was there like why don't you say
a few words and then she got up and
she's like you know during whoever's
battle you know this Foundation was with
us every moment everything like that and
then literally five minutes later I was
doing bits about frozen
yogurt it was the it was like a
nightmare it was just a night you're in
a nightmare and you're look you're doing
the clean set I'm doing a clean set you
can still see the wet faces from the
tears in the audience and you're like
this is the worst I did that one was a
bad one and then I did I did the
Bethesda Country Club which was actually
okay yeah and I just called them all you
know CU they're all just military
industrial complex like defense
contractors and I was just I made fun of
them and they kind of rolled with it cuz
they were all morally compromised people
that's why I like doing comedy in
Washington DC I think cities with with
with tension are good New York has the
tension it's the layout it's the way we
all live and then it's like I think
Boston has that class tension and race
tension and DC has that it's just
morally compromised everybody there
Chicago those are like the best cities
yeah I love
because they have like that that
pressure that's running under that
Ghostbusters 2 molten slime river that
runs under the city that you like that's
what I you know DC has the most of that
a lot of it you ever hear the Jonathan
cats joke where goes I just did a
benefit for the survivors or the benefit
I did last week oh that's great that's a
great line he has some great he's
funny he's a funny writer but uh hope
he's all right I think he's Ms I didn't
mean to bring the room down with that
one sh we'll do a benefit for how old is
he I can't be that old although he's in
a lot of old David mammo movies he just
he co-wrote House of games well Ms can
also be very mild
yeah not really well there's there's it
runs a it's a spectrum I see I did you
watch Dr cats growing up well he's 76 so
okay he had a run hey yeah he's doing
all right was that the ice bucket or was
that something else that's ALS ALS
that's the worst at L yeah really that's
L Garrick yeah because that's L gar
that's like a fivey year it's over and
it's not good it's a tough right but
then the MS is is more of a spectrum
that might have been the last time the
country came together on something was
that and it was also showed you this the
dumbest activism ever like it was like
no no no I'm I'm doing this it's cold
what do you want from me I'm suffering
it's cold I'm in my backyard and we're
doing this and you know and it turns out
it's good for you now Rogan does the
true that's true we were all just that
ice bath is hell I've tried it I got in
a Rogan I got like a toe in I'm like
this this is stupid he loves it and
he's like he braces himself and he gets
in he's like yeah I can't do a cold
shower that's like the last thing I look
forward to in the day I can't lose it
supposedly the people that do the ice
bath say that you are high after that's
what I hear you are like high look at
the Demonic face on the guy yeah I mean
he's look at those nips holy that
seems like it might be edited but maybe
not I hope
soy but that's how you get out all the
uh the online hate you know people come
at the guy so much you got you got to do
a bath yeah got it's like a baptism you
got to cleanse
yourself you
know it's hard I mean internet
mean sorry yeah you do I do see post the
pictures of of the good meals on the
road is that like sometimes yeah we we
um usually there's a place that we've
now been or I've been multiple times so
like I know the people there like now I
you know like you go back to like
Sydney Australia and you have like your
spot or you go to Auckland New Zealand
something crazy you know or whatever
Denver but like yeah now you have the
spots where you like know the people and
you're like oh this is good cuz in the
beginning when you're in the road you
talk about this a lot you're walking on
the side of a on on a on a street
because you car whizzing maybe Ubers
don't comment like why am I going to get
an Uber the Bob Evans I can see it yes
so I just got to walk on the side of
this highway like a heroin addict yeah
so that I can sit people die that way a
lot of people like of and they
should that's also the way you should
die there's no way that you should live
if that's the way you're living that's
how Bill Hicks went I don't know if you
knew that yeah they said it was cancer
yeah don't buy it it but it was you know
so then now you can go to a nice
restaurant the road's different now
because you can go to a nice restaurant
you could stay in a nicer Hotel you
don't have to be I mean you know we used
to stay or I used to stay and I'm sure
you guys did too and like you know know
whatever you could Extended Stay America
or whatever was there residents in yeah
they put you up any the bigger the hotel
the worse the hotel the bigger the room
you're like well this is if it's got a
fridge this is for a divorced man Liv
people are living when you see the
U-Haul in the parking lot this is a
sad weekend well it's tough in
San Antonio I remember I was doing the
old improv which was on the third or
fourth floor of the mall it was not lol
it was the old River Center I remember
that improv and I I went in and I they
were like he goes there's nine people
we're not doing the show and I'm like
all right damn Nine's pretty good then
he goes like this he goes I got great
news I'm like I bet it's not great news
he goes there's 13 and by the way the
room sits 400 goes there's 13 we're good
to go I just he goes I just spoke to
everybody we can do it so we did it it
was fun it was fine but it's like after
that you would walk from the San Antonio
Mall you know under overpasses oh yeah
back to this really shitty whatever it
was residen in or something and you're
you go and and I'd been sober then
probably like 5 six years I'm like this
is the life of a junkie oh yeah that's
what's funny about early comedy you're
like oh this is exactly the life of a
junkie I'm walking under an overpass to
a shitty like motel that people are
living in and hopefully don't kill
myself yeah and hopefully don't kill
myself and then Bobby Kelly's texting me
what cinnamon bun I can get he would
text me it was like the worst support
system ever call me he's like dude go to
Lulu's they have a 2B cinnamon bun I go
oh well that's so good that seems to
make sense yeah well it's like another
junkie calling a junkie like I know the
best spot and then you eat alone when
you're on the road you eat alone oh yeah
so just sitting there well you can't
bring someone at first so when when you
start headlining you're there solo but
that's it's up when I look back
I'm like that's when I got my best
riding done cuz I had best it's true
you're hungriest and you need it and the
feature can't come with you cuz he's 45
and has a day job right right and he's
like he's like do you mind if I sell
these beer koozies I'm like no no no you
do what you have to do you always hear
stories about the guy not letting the
person sell merch and you're like who
the I don't get that let him do
whatever you want I don't care the worst
was when you had to share a room with a
guy you guys ever do that one Mike Rine
I found out he had sleep apnea I think
that was St Germain woke up once in a
night terror and like me was like
shaking me and I was like I was like
what's going on and he's like he goes
I'm sorry I real darkness in me I'm like
what how do you follow it up with that
I'm like this is the craziest how did he
get a guy from Nom's Personality yeah
crazy he went to n yeah he is the
wrestler he is he's the wrestler but
he's a comedian he's like Merl hagger
yeah I did a gig remember True TV is
that still around I don't know I don't
know either that's not a good sign forv
Marine every year would go she'd go
she'd have these meetings with all of us
and she'd bring us in I remember listen
I love all of you she goes I can't give
you a
show I love I'm I'm a huge fan of all of
you I think you're all great she goes I
don't have the power here to do anything
for you but I just want to tell you I go
we just came an hour here I know your
studios are by Columbus Circle we go all
the way up there was no reason for this
come to New York comedy club or the
stand or the seller and go oh we can't
do anything for you she she was a my
manager for years and Jo Liss and Gary
Goldman she it was yeah a lot of a lot
of three-hour meetings that that didn't
go anywhere yeah but good person I like
her a lot I do love her I did one of
those shows for True TV like how to be a
grownup or whatever the they were
and they flew me out to LA they put me
in a what do you call those uh hotels
that you can live in they call like long
stay extended Extended Stay that's it
those are the tough ones people have
their you hear dogs barking that's one
by Go Bananas it was an extended state
America in blue Ohio remember it was the
worst hotel on the planet you couldn't
sleep it was dogs barking there's a full
zoo in there and I talked to Bonnie who
was also on the show and she goes oh
yeah I got him to move me and I'm like
oh I didn't know he could do that
remember those days when you were so new
you didn't want to push it I was also so
new to the road I remember that I didn't
know how bad those hotels were I was
like oh this is cool I'm a young guy in
the road but I remember doing uh laughs
in Kirkland Washington and I was in this
like crackhead motel to the point that a
a crackhead passed out against
you open the window and his head is
against my window I'm like that's
that's dark but I remember in a
pancake house next door she was like
it's great you know I tell Marina I'm
like great Hotel Marina Franklin calls
me she goes you stayed here exactly she
got she got moved obviously but uh but
back then you like that's not yeah it
was nice I think if you're a woman there
there might be more you might have more
of a thing like hey I don't feel safe of
course I can't call up and go hi I feel
very vulnerable I feel vulnerable right
now someone else called when they saw
you yeah right right right they like we
got a real problem here the meth heads
are like let's clear Out Boy
yeah yeah yeah yeah no it's uh it's fun
though but those those Early times are I
think some of the most pure fun that you
have when you're with a bunch of comics
you take a road trip like I remember
Jared freed took me early on he did a
gig in uh where did jar freed he had
like a standing gig at like was it
Foxwoods or I think so it might have
been Foxwood it we just it was just a
road trip with comics and you just got
to go perform and then we'd come home
yeah it's fun you're in a car you're
joking around well you know what it's
like the it's like Katrina Katrina's
obviously horrible devastating but we
had fun we're running around we're
setting fireworks we're looting we're
shooting guns so it's it's deadly and
horrifying but it's also freeing but
then for some people the problem is I
guess Katrina doesn't end
yeah there's still some people now with
fireworks going let's go and you're go
no I have a family you know so it's hard
exactly I remember those that Foxwoods
gig the owner was one of the remember
that older guy who owned it he was the
type of drunk that would always start
crying but now he he went to moan son oh
good and then and they took me out and I
actually like those guys they took me
out for lobster lobster rolls and we ate
lobster rolls but yeah they get
emotional he would he would always start
and i' be like I'm not comfortable with
that but but he would just be like I'm
so happy you're back I'm like why you
why is this a cry I don't know your I
kind of like it a little I like it a
little let me tell you right now when a
grown man starts crying there's
something I go you realize the gravity
of this moment you know I go I'm glad
cuz you know I'm eating a lobster roll
and he he does get wistful oh yeah you
know and he got whisle and I go this is
insane and uncomfortable but he's like
Tammy
pescatelli she doesn't call me anymore
wh in a casino is never good though and
that green room they were just stocking
like be it was like it was hell I hated
that gig always that a tough gig cuz
everybody loses money then they come to
your show and they hate you you you mean
and Christ Stephano did it a long time
ago we had this writer following us this
guy Scott Rob who's a great writer he
wrote a bunch of guy from Cleveland very
very bright guy and he uh he was in The
Green Room he was like they treat you
like like the way they talk to us he was
like this is crazy I always think if my
parents could see this they'd be like
come on what are you doing but now it's
great now it's fine now it's good you
get there you graduate it takes
connected through a struggle which is
kind of interesting yeah it's boot camp
baby I call it m comp yeah people
listening to this going oh
really we're like it's like a war really
you play stri mall I'm the strip STP
people like really a struggle huh okay
it was fun it was fun it's fun the the
the hardest things are the funnest it
was so fun living I lived in a a
fivestory walk up on the fifth flooor uh
I had a a shower in my kitchen I know
who you lived with and you know who I
Liv with and that was I mean wof oh yeah
and it was it was Cosby but but it was
just fun it was always fun you got to go
on the roof and you'd smoke a cigarette
do you smoke no but I would back then I
did because like you now I can't you get
in the mid-30s you got to go no I'm in
the late 30s now but it's like
eventually you have to say no but like
when you're 25 there's no reason not to
have a cigarette anyone listening is 25
yeah uh there's just no reason not to
especially when you're on a roof and you
want to talk about who got JFL
exactly there's nothing better you light
up the cigarette you're like God damn it
yeah and the nicotine's kicking in yeah
you're like I've been pounding the
payment three years what is that
personality right well we all we're
talking about how rough the beginning
was do you think you can bypass that now
with the Tik toks and the reals and all
the podcast Griffin had a great line
years and years ago and said she said
this is Trump no she um she said uh you
pay your dues now or later oh say it
again you pay your dues now or later uh
so what's interesting is like that's
great I I do think there's going to be a
time in every career even if it is a
rocket ship right where you're going to
level off or something all you know like
interesting I do think eventually you do
have you can't avoid it forever you
might not have to go to do what we did
but again we're admitting what we did
it's fun yeah sure the does some people
have to pay aren't fun Imagine because
here's the deal some people are going to
get really successful early on and make
a lot of money and then for whatever
reason things really cool off and people
don't care I would wager that's harder
yeah it's actually harder when you're
not young and broke and you have that
camaraderie and you're like like
you have that energy of like we're all
doing it and everything like that but
when you just get to a certain point and
you know cuz some of that's isolating
right some of the like succeeding and
all that stuff can be isolating and then
then having to pay those dues or figure
something out right might be harder you
might not you might not be equipped I
mean when you're younger it's like
you're building towards it but if it
just hits you at like in your 40s that
is it is weirder right and everybody
kind of turns on you when you pop quick
and don't have to do all the the Dos but
that that I think that's just
Instinct I don't like it either and you
got to fight it as a comedian CU
sometimes sometimes someone will pop and
you're like why I'm just being a
contrarian cuz everyone is obsessed and
they'll like be like this is the
greatest and you have to be like it's
fine it's fine it's not it's not bad
either it's yeah I think that people are
invested in like a certain thing where
it's like a certain sequence of events
of people that have paid their dues but
again it's like there's things people
are doing that we're not
seeing that's the other thing right
really there you know sorry there
are you know that's part of it right
it's like you know it's like who knows
people do things and that we just don't
know them you know yeah like if some
guys's magician for 5 years and then
becomes a comedian does really well at
it for two or three it's like the guy
was a was you know what I mean I'm not
know I don't know if that's ever
happened everyone you know I mean it's I
think people if you don't know a person
it's harder but if you know that they're
hustling there's a documentary
called Magic Camp I say that to say this
I always have an agenda when I say
something there's a documentary called
Magic camp and it's about these kids who
want to be magicians and it's so sad
because like the yeah here it is and I
saw it years ago and they're all trying
to be magicians and succeeding as a
magician there's like two guys that have
residencies in Vegas exactly and then
everybody else their success is like I
drive a Ford windar to a birthday party
I get out in the back I do the thing
people are happy we are lucky in the
sense that we are in a thing that when
it can be good like when you are a
magician it really cannot be good and
there's three three guys there's like
three it's like David Copperfield Lance
Burton David bla and and David Blaine
it's all David's and and Chris Angel
maybe tell do you know that's fine but
we're talking in history now so it's
like it's like imagine if your passion
there was no root here there's a root
there's a roote and there's a lot of us
and there's a lot of people doing great
there's a middle class in entertainment
unlik class yeah there people are like
so I was looking at like like I'm lucky
that I didn't want to do something that
was so even actors when you're just an
actor the idea that you're just an actor
and you have no you can't do you can't
do anything else and you just have to
wait for somebody to go you got the part
that would that would kill me that would
kill me the waiting and uh but I I do
think when we started stand up like I
would watch the half hours on Comedy
Central and be like that's what I didn't
know that a lot of those guys were
struggling to fill rooms on weekends oh
yeah but like I just watched it like
that's awesome sag after strike
has just ended which means the very
demoralizing process of me sitting in a
room with like Shawn Donnelly and they
go all right come in and you just sit
there and they go now remember you have
your night stick in your hand and CU
every role is like you know cop or like
you know gambling addict who SE his
daughter yeah once a month alcoholic dad
police
supervision you know Fair worker you
know who's poetic you know smart fairy
word but but it's just it's like one of
those things where you go thank God and
I like act I think it's fun to do but
you're in the Eli Roth movie I'm in the
Thanksgiving movie that comes out which
is cool they cut my head off and I'm in
another thing I can't talk about that
you know a little bit about but maybe
they edited me out I don't know they
might edit me out that's why I never
told anyone and someone I'm not telling
them now it sounds like I am but I'm not
yeah but the thing is it's just being on
set with those things it's like actors
are you know they're just interesting in
the sense that like they don't have any
power over what they do they have to
wait until somebody says you can we can
be proactive in 10 different ways 100%
And they can write something and act in
it or direct it but you still need the
the money you got to produce it you got
to fund it it's it's a of work just
meetings dude you realize how much you
realize like I'm working with a guy now
who's like man agents don't respond to
emails I'm like yeah yeah it's like it's
like well mine does if it's from the
Capital
Grill so what I do is I always put that
in the header I think it was more a
general thing I mean look I like who I'm
with but it's I think it's more of a
general thing he's like he's like dude
managers don't do and I'm like yeah
we know that but yeah uh but it's one of
those things managers are fun guys yeah
that's their thing they're just a fun
guy they drink with it they get the tab
they're a fun guy they get a lunch CU I
have one I hired one it's weird you go
so long with that one you go I'm gon to
get one again I have I just hired who's
great he's like the arguably the biggest
I guess comedy manager and he's good
he's really good but it's just at what
they do yeah which is what it is they're
just like they butter you up they buy
you two Bud Lights and take a cut of
your whole theater they just go they
just go you're funny man yeah
they go you know I laugh man you know
they go I don't laugh a lot but when
you I laugh and I like it man you're
giving them 10% to be they go then they
go like this they go why aren't you in
White
Lotus I'm like I don't know there's 30
reasons go why aren't you in White Lotus
I go I don't really know he goes I think
that's what you should be by the way
White Lotus season 3 is in Thailand so
can you imagine at like a wellness spot
yeah could you imagine something I
belong in less than White Lotus season 3
at a Thai Wellness Retreat can you
imagine yeah yeah I mean and hearing me
be like is everything okay with your
room you know it's just like all right
right white lad is season 8 when it's in
Boston that like it's it's at The Encore
casino that's in Boston that's what I'll
do it you're in Yonkers go I'll play
Jennifer kage's
role yeah dude that's like uh but that
but the Eli Roth thing sounds cool it's
really cool because it's a horror movie
so it's like the one thing Hollywood
really can still do is like I have a
great Happ oh I can't well oh god well
but they know they can see me getting
gred in the trailer you see the blood
and it's just fun to have knives in you
and everybody's bleeding and then
everybody's eating uh uh you know at the
craft Services table and we're all
bloody and there's knives it's just a
cool horror movies are just cool yeah
it's just fun so it's like a cool thing
to do that is so cool are you a big
horror person I love horror movies so
I've always liked them and like I you
know especially this time of year yes
like Halloween Thanksgiving like this
feels like a real popcorn family turn
this on the house how did this role come
about for you well Eli's just a fan of
the podcast and he's a really cool dude
and he just gave me this opportunity and
I I you know was like thank you that's
kind of what it is he seems like a cool
guy he's an awesome guy he's the Bear
Jew man I I I I auditioned for another
thing and I wasn't right for it the bear
yeah the bear um and and he I I
was it wasn't for me he was like you did
great I did like a bunch of auditions
for it he's like you did really good you
were close but it just wasn't for you
and I was like no I get it you know and
then this thing he was like I I think
something here is really good because
they wanted they wanted you to be fun
there was this role they go we want you
to be funny yeah so I was like great
like this is great so I was really
pumped it was really exciting that's
really the only way for us to get no
I've auditioned for 9,000 things never
gotten one you got to know the director
you got to have a podcast they got to
put you in that's it the time stuff
they've just been like here it's never
I've never booked no cuz there are
people that are out there that um you
know are actors yeah yeah that's their
job like so they're known and they have
res like long resumes and things they've
done which I totally get he's like the
guy that we went with he goes for the
other thing he's like he did all of
these things I go right well of course
yeah yeah yeah if shy laof is in the
room and then I show up I'm not getting
it and that's fair give it to the the
star just the that's great man that's
great that you're in that well it's fun
and and uh you know I think it's good
and um the other one was hard the other
one I was in was hard and the director
was yelling at me because I was not
remembering the
blocking it was tough I had a similar
thing and he was he was yelling at
everybody but he's yelling at me he
would come up to me goes I don't know
why you're this up and I'm like
I'm sorry I you know and he's like he
goes it's not hard you move the book 70%
across the desk 80% it's out of frame
you turn around and deliver half of your
line when he opens the door you wait for
him you deliver the other half when he
picks up the phone you start to say the
second part of your line but you're
looking around and then you finish the
second part of your line okay and then
he's like you wait a while but not too
long to do the third line what's the
problem let's go and and there's
80 people watching you with cameras and
I'm just like and there's some of the
biggest actors in the world around you
and you're just like oh my God like it's
hard yeah like how hard is that well
last night I uh at my job I was drunk so
the other things easier that's what I
felt like when I did America's Got
Talent they're all like stretching and
having to be in the perfect place and I
remember being like oh I can I can be
wasted right like what standup is loose
and fun and this is so you you miss one
thing in acting you're like yeah it's
it's tough It's really weird cuz we're
such standups who work so hard at it you
hone it and all they want you to do is
not be a standup all the time like a
morning show they're like hey don't
don't say anything you would say on
stage like that's my whole thing yeah
but that's these morning shows we're
we're also they we're watching they're
at the end there's like three of them
left that's why I like doing them going
to be like Relic I'm glad that we were
the like last maybe generation of people
to do that like morning radio new day
Cleveland his legendary thing like like
it's funny to watch these morning shows
because they're over so pointless and
they're pointless and like the people on
them don't even like I remember when you
grew up like the morning shows they
would kind of be attractive people oh
yeah now it's like slobs is it really
yeah they're not they're like sitting
there and you're like what like and and
they're not particularly charismatic or
anything it's just like it's the bottom
of the barrel it's what's left it's what
remains yeah it's it's like a dating app
after 50 yeah exactly they're just like
let's throw these two people out well
the phone takes everything away I need
to know the traffic I need to know the
weather I need to know the news and now
I have all that on my phone why do I
need to hear it from Boston radio shows
Maddie in the morning right all these
things like uh you know Lauren and wall
like these old old school they're in
your car and I love that especially cuz
we we podcast and stuff like that like
the history I feel like of radio and
broadcasting and the history of standup
comedy always kind of had you know been
complimentary right Stern and O Anda and
the the whole thing so like those
prested and Steve any of those shows
that can help you sell tickets when you
go on in the beginning if you are funny
on those shows people are listening and
that you can sell tickets so it's like
to me it's interesting seeing like how
that evolves too oh yeah oh yeah and
there's the good ones are still around
it's always changing like Lucille Ball
that was like a radio person then it's I
Lucy like the business is always going
to be changing it's a good thing you got
to you got to adapt to your and
comes back too with black face yeah
Lucio ball racist it's back in yeah well
she had a Puerto Rican hubby trueb Fair
sorry Cuban yeah whiteb that was that
was controversial at the time yeah who
had that funny joke it's like uh back in
the in the 50s you had to you couldn't
have a pregnant woman on TV that was
like an edgy and then now you can't say
woman on TV I can't remember who had it
was it was a funny bit sorry brought but
there's nothing new it's funny there's
nothing new to be there's no edgy now oh
you can always go edgy you can always go
edgy edgy now is like being religious
right a good point right it goes the
other way yeah exactly cuz all the young
kids now are like devout Catholics cuz
it's the only way to be like you
Mom right CU their mother has like green
hair and you know and they're like
you Mom I'm a devout Catholic they're
saying the Ros that's how they pissed
their parents off yeah you know right
nuclear family whoa yeah like what yeah
it's interesting yeah it's all it all
comes around would you ever adopt a kid
do you think either I don't know adopt I
don't know about adopt so a real
lifestyle change yeah kids are weird
because all our friends are doing in
vitro or whatever it's called it's like
10 grand a pop they really want a kid
and then all the other people I know are
murdering like they they're aborting so
kids are
really kids are really on the spectrum
of like I really want one or I feel like
it's just that's one of those questions
where like you a town hall with a
presidential candidate you're like
Governor D
Santa let me ask you a question some of
my friends are doing in vitro 10 grand a
pop other ones are murdering aborting
you know where do you stay how do we
solve this I know it's hard there's
nothing in the middle I always think
about getting a dog I always go I always
see a dog in a window and I go I should
just get a dog right cuz you're great
then I'm like I travel a lot I don't
know if it's fair whatever uh when you
have a kid I fully believe that your
entire life has to be oriented around
your child yeah and why I'm So Pro
people having kids is because at a
certain point I think it would it's kind
of it's it's necessary for a lot of
people to step out of their own
interests and into more of a collective
family interest I think that makes a lot
of sense especially for comedians
especially for comedians so I I would
never say no but I would say it would
require a massive lifestyle change yeah
and it takes the narcissism out of you a
little bit what about you how do you
feel about it you don't know it's hard
to know yeah I'm not I'm like you man
I'm on the road con I do think adoption
is interesting because like there are a
lot of kids that are um needing of
homes yeah you know what I mean yeah and
you get the black points get a black kid
would be good and have them sell merch
yeah just a three-year-old selling merch
I'll get i'll get a Chinese kid he'll
Stitch the merch save some
points Chinese Gods son who I never
would have said yes but he's Chinese
he's like a little Asian baby too cute
he's a killer he's Asian and it just
intimidates people when they see an
Asian child because they know he's the
future course you got to get a
Palestinian kid really mix it up you got
starter too yes yes I don't hate them
look really confused if I had a problem
how many of you saved that's a good
that's right yeah yeah you're tearing
kids posters down I'm adopting them yeah
yeah what an odd move to Terra poster
it's strange what an odd move no matter
how you feel I think it's the worst
thing that's happened with the whole
it's just an odd move I think it's the
there's nothing worse than that it's a
good point nothing worse nothing worse
by the way though and and I'll be honest
let's also go the other way for a minute
I'm also not a fan of
posters I'm not a fan of mucking up a
lot of I don't love a
poster and I also don't love the tearing
down of a poster but it's like I don't
like I've never been a fan of like a lot
of posters sure sure we should go back
to the milk carton right we know but
here's the other thing we know it
happened yeah we have the internet and
we we no one's happy can we fit 10,000
faces on a
Cardon that would that would problem go
missing a lot yeah it's a lot lot of
missing and you guys can't do dairy so
put it on pork there you
go that too are you guys working on any
bits this might be a good I got nothing
dude wait what about a peeve yeah give
me a peeve o the peeve I got one and
this one I can't hasn't come up on this
show how about this guy you go out to
eat with him you finish the meal
everything's great and you get this
one you know the teeth sucker yeah you
know all night he's got the steak piece
in his teeth and he's
like man that was good
dinner I'm just like what are you doing
go to the bathroom go to the bathroom
yeah the teeth sucker the guy who brings
the little floss pick too oh that guy
why is that a thing in public yeah he
pulls out of a case
do in public what you allow them to do
like people really will unless you push
back if you look at plain Behavior how
that's degenerated it's it's degenerated
to a point where people are having fist
fights they're naked on the plane if you
don't push back that is not
real right right they're
AI abortions on the likeness you so I if
if you don't push back people tend to do
what they're allowed to do good point
bad people yeah bad people they take
advantage of what they're allowed to do
that's so true I remember one of the
best things I've ever seen is we have a
flight I'm flying back from God Only
Knows Syracuse Buffalo I think I did the
egg I like the egg eggs cool shout out
to the beautiful venue lovely venue and
we're coming back and you know you're in
a little jat the Pilot's young
there's one flight attendant and there's
maybe I don't know 17 of us with the
privilege of going back to guia and
there's a guy there and I mean it's a
41-minute flight yeah if that it is
cruising for like five minutes and then
it descent a guy goes like this to the
flight T he goes yo you got any
pancakes to the attendant or the flight
attendant swear to God she goes she goes
no he goes all right then he turns to
his chick and he goes that's kind of
up she's got a gdle back there what he
yeah like he thought there'd be a full
breakfast it's a 41-minute flight he
goes yeah it's a little up it was
just funny the Injustice yes yeah it's
kind of up huh that's kind of
up you know and then for a minute
I agreed with him I'm like yeah why not
H but that's how it happens that's it
because you start being unreasonable it
it can spread yes it can spread because
when someone's being unreasonable it is
hard to go against them and it's much
easier to join them and go you know I
would like a pancake you forget the mob
you
forget you become a part of the m and
the mob wins if they get the numbers
yeah so that is scary I think it's
connected a lot to the social media
though cuz just being an outrageous
will get you retweets now yeah
squeaky wheel baby and it does turn when
you're on a flight it you become that
you're like I'll be an too
instead of being like you're an
it's easier to be like I'll be an
too I'll P I'll the guy who
takes off the shoes next to you and
you're like you haven't taken a shower
in weeks
between the seats it's crazy but that
pancake guy is online he's the one
commenting on your sh I'm sure you guys
saw the video of the guy leaning back on
the flight putting his hands behind the
pull it up you've seen that the hands
behind the chair I mean it's just it's a
pig back there that's crazy
what's he doing let's see this is it a
BD yeah it's a is this because flights
got cheaper well what happened well
Janelle James had a great joke she goes
bus people are flying now I think that
was that was on her Netflix I thought
that was a good way this isn't it it's
the most wonderful time of the year
nobody wants to spend in the kitchen
with Factor America's number one ready
to eat meal kit saving time is a total
Breeze Factor deliver Chef prepared
dietician approved meals right to your
door they're always fresh never Frozen
just heat them up in 2 minutes and
dinner is served choose some over 35
weekly meal options including awesome
breakfast like apple cinnamon pancakes
and bacon and cheddar egg bites with so
many choices there's something everyone
will love I like all this stuff you love
the shakes oh yeah the smoothies are
killer great flavors lot of good options
here vegan vegetarian keto calorie smart
and Protein Plus meal options no matter
what your goals are factor can help you
get there head to factor meals.com drunk
50 and use code drunk 50 to get 50% off
that's code drunk @actor meals.com drunk
5 and get 50% off liquid
IV I love this It's Beginning to Look a
Lot Like Christmas between holiday
travel hosting the family dinner and
shopping you got to stay hydrated with
liquid IV with three times the
electrolytes of leading sports drinks
plus eight vitamins and nutrients for
everyday Wellness no matter what you're
up to liquid IV will keep you hydrated
liquid IV hydrates twice as fast as
regular water alone and it's available
in three flavors sugar-free white peach
green grape and lemon lime no artificial
sweeteners in it you just get amazing
flavor with that without that gross
bitter aftertaste I keep keep a bag of
these on the Shelf I pop one every day
I'm hung over I'm I'm working out I got
it in the road pouch cuz you know you
get a hangover on the road you or you
just feel dehydrated it's good for the
gym too yeah that's true hydration is
key you want those parts oiled up grab
your liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free and bulk nationwide at Costco
or you can get 20% off when you go to
liquid iv.com and use code drunk at
checkout that's 20% off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today you us promo code drunk at liquid
iv.com it's it's recent that's fake
that's not it in the passenger not only
punch the seat also isn't it funny now
by the way that terrorism's the least of
anyone's
concerned like by the way the nicest
thing you bump into is like a quiet
Islamic terrorist that's the easiest
thing on a flight now you're just like
okay right yeah you're like okay so all
you're going to do is charge the cockpit
but you're going to be quiet and not
bother me fine in instead of like the
movie World Trade Center we're just
think it's like a curb episode every
you're like this dude's an
well yeah go to go to Twitter
maybe okay bus people that is dead go to
the cess pool of X I mean the the yeah
no huh I mean the Greyhounds were
really it's tough I used to take Mega
buses Washington DC and i' do the little
room with the DC Improv like the front
is that's the double decker one right
which one
yes and we would go there and I would
put the you you put your headphones in
and then you would just turn around and
be like a chihuahua in a bag someone had
a chihuahua in like a bag and with a
couple holes in it yeah and there was
feeding potato chips yes and then you'd
be like this is where I'm at in my life
and then you would you would get out in
DC and do the show and then you'd be
like okay and then like the worst thing
was standing on that line in the morning
oh the worst the worst is you're on the
line and they're unhappy with you cuz
you paid like $3 to get it so they're
like getting the line yelling at you
it's a great deal they're hit you with
that cattle B you're doing the math like
how are you making any money and then
you pay I used to pay a couple of
dollars extra to be in like that
Premiere line oh yeah and you could so
then you would like board first and you
you're like how could this get any worse
then you hear like cling cling cling
cling you're like oh he's playing a
casino game nice it's only four hours
but then you look at people on it who
are like I was like well I'm on this cuz
I'm trying to be a comedian and I have a
job and then you look at people and
they're 40
and 50s and you're like oh yeah he's
seeing his daughter so the he's going
because he got a lead on a job out of
state but doesn't want to put money down
for the room rental until he knows if he
gets the job so he's got to go and and
and and hear about this job because you
know he just got out of jail and it's
been seven years and if he gets his job
he's going to take a room rental in
Baltimore and you go this is tough that
is tough take it to Baltimore too you
get the the the move back then was you
take the midnight bus back I did the
same because instead of having to pay
another hotel so you take the midnight
busz back and that's when you see the
animal that's when the free come
out it's full on drug mes yeah so the
bus is people from Baltimore and lowend
Drug mules you're not getting their fat
it's fat mules and then they go
yeah it's right and then they get out at
the Port Authority oh yeah and we're all
getting out at the Port Authority and
that's the final stop in New York is
porar right so then you just get let out
at 3:30 4: a.m. in the nightmare of
nightmares and you're like great and I
live thank God on 45th between 8th and
9th so I would just kind of like Scurry
to my thing but yeah I mean it's just a
nightmare it's a haunted house in there
that was back then when you you'd have a
girl I'd have a girl waiting for me and
she'd be like what are you doing with
your life and you have to be like I
don't it's it doesn't add up I'm trying
to make it I'm living my dream yeah yeah
the worst was funwa that was beneath
meab I never did that those were the
chin1 it was $1 to go to Boston but it
took about three days but man that was
tough it was like a cage of chickens me
and Sarat tamos used to take the old
school Uber pools oh yeah because we
both lived in atoria and here's what the
old school Uber pools would do they
would never stop picking people up yeah
so what the Uber pool was like there was
that there were times when me and toage
would sit in a car for an hour yeah
after our spot at the stand right we
would have been home and asleep if we
but like they'll just keep circling
Murray
Hill and it just doesn't end and then
event I think is uberpool done now it's
got to be it's got to be done speed day
got rid of it right La it was
bad in la oh it's I wouldn't think I'm
like I'm just trying to save money in
between uh meetings I've been in an Uber
pool in LA and an Uber pool in La starts
to get weird like you would get in and
there'd be two people like hey what's
what's up and they be like hi and every
starts talking you know like this is
kind of and then everyone I I've been in
them where people start exchanging
numbers and you go this is crazy
networking I got I got in once and a
girl just got in and was crying and I
was like I'm not I'm not touching this
one I'm just by the way we're going to
explain this to people it is one of the
funniest things explain also Airbnb
which I think's on its way out a little
bit because I think people are realizing
the insanity of what happened with you
and airbn I'm not allowed on the
platform there were two lesbians they
had a house in Joshua Tree we cooked a
dinner we had fried fish we had Burgers
we had baked beans nothing crazy
Americana and what happened was these
women uh made me pay a cleaning fee and
then also just destroyed me in the
reviews gave me a horrible rating and we
didn't do anything that bad it was just
some dishes right so I threatened to
kill them and I didn't not not not
directly but I was just like I hope you
know in a funny way I hope the house
doesn't burn down I called them desert
dkes it was a whole thing it was all
thing because I the cleaning fee which
is again why Airbnb is tanking it's lost
half of its value it's almost over
because people are going why am I paying
you
$500 for a cleaning fee which is two
weeks of a cleaning lady yeah and then
you're hitting me because it's four
dishes in the sink right this is crazy
so I'm banned from airb they won't let
me back on I've had big people try to
get me on it won't work wow um and it is
what it is I don't want to go to some
strangers home I I've never done it the
insanity of during the pandemic hotels
were you know the restaurants were
closed everything was all common areas
in a hotel were closed they didn't have
ma service it was weird I get the appeal
of an Airbnb oh there's a pool we can
sit outside had some good ones maybe
like Phoenix you go Phoenix get a nice
but now the amount of rules how how
weird they're being about everything the
weird
voyerism is going the way of U Uber pool
whereas when we describe it to people
it's going to sound insane they're going
cuz you just got in a car with strangers
and they would get dropped off and then
another stranger would get in and then
you would be you're on a queue to get
dropped off eventually yes EX in a tiny
little car I mean it's crazy the same
way showing up to an airb I've showed up
to airbnbs where it was clear the family
was living there up until when I showed
up like 10 minutes and you're like oh my
God like the shower was still steaming
like like some poor guy just got his
family and goes we're in the camper
tonight yeah it it's sick it's actually
disg coming in the middle of the night
to use the bathroom yeah it's disgusting
it's really sick would always try to
turn me onto it he'd be like it's the
best I get a three four bedroom I bring
the whole crew and I'm just like yeah
that's what I want I want to hear Gary
Veer jerking off in the Next Room yeah
it was fine for the moment I think
during the pandemic all those things
were good where you were like yeah we
got a house now what if we lived in
Houston it was also like people were
vacationing in in like other alternate
realities yes so they were like what if
I lived here that was the pandemic and
the pandemic everybody's like moving
around people some people bought houses
other places some people were like what
if I lived here you went to Austin for I
lived in Austin for while for a year you
know and you hated it I couldn't do it
it wasn't for me I love my friends that
live there I love Joe I love the club I
I just am not a guy I like oceans I like
you know I like just where I kind of
grew up like I love New York City I I
like La at took a while to like LA but I
I do like La now would you ever come
back to where newor York of course I
would come back here sure really for
sure Austin's a college town at the end
of day a college town and it's you know
but I I get it I get why people are
living there I'm not a huge fan of the
BBS same so it doesn't mean I hate them
it means that like it's not for you la
suburbs aren't BBS do you know what I
mean like I like I could get to Sunset
Boulevard real quick and I'm like this
is is a city it's not New York it's not
a Miami Chicago New York type of city
but it's a city Austin is a tiny little
city surrounded by a lot of sleepy
suburbs MH and if you're into it like if
you like I have a family and the kids
are in playing soccer and stuff it's
great um but for me it just well I I
like a little more stuff going on yeah
no I get that I get it it get excuse me
it gets old quick cuz you can do
everything in two weeks in Austin you
and La make sense to me you and Austin
didn't really make sense yeah I I like
you're like a guy who soaks up culture
and like I see you getting like funny
Hollywood stories yeah I get I go to
dinner with people like I really soda
will talk about this like I take
meetings with people which nothing's
ever going to happen but I'll take
meetings with very high level people
who's the most high level person I don't
know president of CBS or something and I
tell them why they're wrong about
everything they've done Les Moon and
they and they just they kind of Nod and
they go I kind of understand what you
mean I go I I go I know the funniest
people in the world and you guys are
it up you're throwing it you're
throwing it away they need to hear that
and then they go they go yeah you're
probably right but they go what do you
want you know I go yeah right yeah
because the deal is it's like changing
the government right people don't
realize right so it's like those
companies are big cruise ships that you
can kind of tilt a little bit like this
sure um but I always say like I know the
funniest people like you know and and
and they should all every they should
get shots I should get a shot all my
friends should get shots but they can't
take a risk it's too much money they
scared it's I think they're going to
start to now because I think they've
lost enough money where they're going to
start to but that's what's fun to me
about La is it's like there's something
to sink your teeth into and it's it's
all going wrong which I find really
interesting and really good for comedy
the city's going wrong it's devolving
the industry is changing no one needs to
be there anymore people are mentally ill
they're un talking their phone in the
middle of the street they're like What's
Up guy you know it's sick it's a sick
place of sick people who are dying and
they're desperate and they're all
crawling around like lizards and they
know it's over we all know it's over and
we know we're going to meet a bad end
right but that I feel like is a very
healthy way to get it's entertaining I
love it I rather it I love to sit in an
LA coffee shop and just hear the
desperation of the keys on the backb
this is the one that's going to change
it it's a buddy cop movie no one's done
one of these livs the wire it's ozar
they're all
trans um so to me it's like fun whereas
it's like in Austin there's something
about everybody loves it New York what I
loved about New York is like in New York
uh if you were like if you say to a New
Yorker this city is A New Yorker
will turn around go you have no idea how
shitty it is exactly and and I'm losing
my mind dude right so everyone will
always complain about New York which I
think is a very healthy way to live yeah
I think it's very healthy in Austin
people just look at you and they're like
this is the pl and that to me it feels
cult-like and there's hope there
everybody keeps moving there for this
hope like my world's going to change
there's no hope here and that's and I'm
holding on to that I love the no hope
yesterday Mark and I are on the train
and I got this dog in the little pouch
and uh some how about that guy
in the train yesterday he he across the
you ever someone tried to talk to you
across the train so it's like a bunch of
people have to listen to the
conversation you go he goes hey a pug
and I was like oh yeah got a dolly with
love pugs and we're like oh yeah think
we figured that that he just keeps going
he's like he's like I had a pug dead and
we're like why you putting this in my
head why you doing this to me well the
mental illness is so great here oh yeah
great and there is and there are moments
where I saw this band outside of New
York comedy club and I don't know if I'm
going to do this but this is just a New
York moment I might not do it but I
think just thinking about it good he was
like a guy had a bass and he I go are
you guys a band and they go yeah I'm
like would you play I got a gig on
Friday would you play while people got
seated and I was like it's a carnegy
hall and they were like really and I
might disband I might just choose them I
got to watch watch your stuff later but
maybe I'll just choose them to like play
while people are I think it's a very
nice way to open a big show I think it's
a great way to open a Big Show and it's
just a weird New York moment of seeing
these guys they were in a rehearsal
space so they are rehearsing oh you'd
blow their minds so how amazing would
that be like they're like some dude they
didn't know who I was they were like are
you're a ComEd then some one crazy fan
like follow me out a New York comedy
club he's
like so I'm like see see I'm a comedian
see this sick person has identified with
things I've done yes um but so it might
be like one of those moments where it's
like that's the cool about the city
that I love it's just that R those
random moments that you don't get other
plac but that's the problem with LA is
that guy that band is waiting for you
like where's my produc my book you'll
get an email from that band's manager so
what are we what kind of money are we
talking about exactly what kind of money
are we talking here they're like that's
amazing I Carnegie Hall I had a musical
opener at the MSG theater and it was it
people loved it think it's a good
thing yeah I think it's a good thing
we're going to figure it out uh you know
the beginning of a big show is always
weird anyway because people are seating
and you can't really be doing comedy so
music is perfect I think music's good
yeah and it's it's it's different people
pay it's like they can kind of still
chat a little bit we still enjoying it
it's yeah it's yeah it's kind of good or
I was thinking maybe an opera
singer an opera singer might be fun to
stand an opera singer there and like
pianist just doing piano and then have
like a soprano like singing opera that's
funny also that's funny so they may win
they may beat the band because it's
actually funnier so serious yeah but
imagine that I did put the band on and
that it was a great night for them
that's a real New York moment it's not
going to happen but Mark and I used to
we used to open for Schumer in these big
Arenas and she would have her brother's
Jazz Trio open and it was like a really
classy way to show people loved it I I
had a Christmas party in La we had a
jazz Trio during the Christmas party
took it up another notch a jazz Trio in
the corner doing Christmas jazz yeah
yeah and it was awesome it was
killer we had that at my wedding I was
at a bar once in Sacramento just like
like a live kind of old it felt like I
was an LA Confidential it's
awesome it feels classier wherever you
are I like jazz cuz the people that do
it they go we're not getting famous
we're not going to get rich but we love
this music so much we look at it it's
historic it has importance we love it
and it's a you know we do it and we do
it at a high level because we love it I
think that's a really cool type of music
it's the opposite of Comedy it's the
absolute opposite yeah and it's like you
could listen to it while you work while
you just like take a walk and you could
still think it's it's perfect
it's perfect like background noise yeah
you never see a jazz musician like hey
hey no one's listening you know no
they're never like shut up get off your
phone although you these things where
like musicians like I used to not think
musicians like could feel a bomb but
I've seen musicians in venues where they
just don't acknowledge them at all and
I'm like that sucks interesting
you see it affect the performance
they're not giving themselves to it well
sociopathy is great though because I've
had actors open for me who've asked they
go can I open for you and they just go
up and they bomb and they go I think
that was good actors try they try yeah
just for the first time no jokes and
they get like one half of a laugh in a
five minute set which is rough because
then there's four minutes and 45 seconds
of tough but then they'll just look you
go I think that was kind of good so you
know you never know how someone is
internalizing it oh yeah some people
have no self awareness at all like it's
one thing to be a really chubby person
and wear like really provocative clothes
to make a point and go you it's
another thing to think you look good
yeah of course there are those people
who go no no no this is hot and you go
oh you know as Christopher Hitchin said
how far the termites have buried and how
long and how well they've
dined you know what I mean that was
powerful what I mean yeah it's like it's
like some people just are not so you're
looking at them going oh I'm in the room
and I'm watching this person but but a
lot of them are just like that was great
cuz you we've all seen comics on stage
where like they're not in the room of
course of course those are the people
you're lighting eight times they don't
know they're just they get mad too
they're like I got it yeah and you're
like well it's been you're doing 24 and
you're supposed to do seven so you got
so they don't know like my manager said
to me he goes you know when you do a
seven you know when you do a four he
goes the awareness is key it's key to
know it's key to walk up stage and go
okay that one was great that one was
very good might be more important than
funny oh yeah huge cuz if you're not if
you're funny but you don't know when or
I mean you're not funny yeah that's true
awareness is huge awareness is big and
also uh and the delusion in this Biz is
bananas well the thing is you need it
you need it which is interesting like
you need it in the beginning you need it
in the beginning and you don't know how
much of it you need you got to find the
level of it that's good yeah and then
you just got to Tinker with it and then
you know it's it's help it's one of
those things where it's like it's
necessary but it can also kill you yeah
that is true other it's maybe it's like
rage in a boxer you need it in the
beginning but you also don't want to
kill somebody in the room right yeah you
got to you got to know you got to
believe these things are possible when
the evidence is saying they're not yes
yes like it's one of those jobs where
you tell people for the first few years
that you're doing it and it's like it's
a polite they go oh that's good yeah
yeah that's nice we were talking about a
comic last night it was me Mark Colin
Quinn and Jim nordon we were talking
Quinn was telling a story about this
comic who's like I got the perfect
opener for any benefit and Quinn saw him
do it at a benefit and it ate and
then he ate and uh and he didn't
realize it he thought it went great and
that's that's a horrible like he
that Quinn was like that he's had a
great life he doesn't know that's
horrible Governors once we like young
Comics we just came out from the city to
do governors we had a guy sit down he
goes let me tell you about the business
this guy's like you know and we're like
okay and then he does a whole like 20
minutes about like here's what it is
yeah you know he does his whole thing
because you got to start at the prom
show and we're like
okay it couldn't be more wrong right
couldn't be more wrong but he's given us
his whole thing about he's like you got
to make sure your manager not you know
this weird like and then he got up and
just ate it y for 10 minutes just bomb
for 10 minutes and then came off stage
looked at us he goes they were good of
course so the level of insanity is high
well how many comedy teachers you these
comedy classes the teachers are always
bombers well Jessica kuron did one back
in the day imagine having her as a
teacher open m she T there there there
are exceptions I'd say it's 99 to one I
took one when I started and Joe Macky
was in it with me and and I guarantee
you're funnier than the teacher probably
were you in that famous one it was rine
no there was one where it was like ween
to St there was like a big one that a
lot of people it was me and Macky and no
one else who did it but at the time
you're like that guy's fun
random people you're like that was good
I mean well there's all these people
that you'll see in open mike right who
are really funny yeah there's some
people some of the funniest people
you'll see you just see like twice I
know and then they just disappear right
like there are some really funny people
you go that guy was really funny or that
girl was great and then they just
disappear so it is such an interesting
thing about like sticking with it sure
is hard it's tough life gets in the well
there's a lot there seems to be this
this Chasm between talent and then
driven and ambitious and like knowing
how to promote yourself and you need
that now I feel I feel like that one's
more important now I know but they're
they're rarely both you really see the
hilarious guy like this girl you'll see
an open mike she doesn't have that that
business sense no she's like uh somebody
who's like I got this thing inside of me
I got to get out yeah and it's really
funny and interesting and different and
then you don't see her again cuz she
hung herself exactly but had she not
yeah she might have been you know might
have been on a remake picture like took
the picture Maria Bamford getting off
stage and just like handed out business
cards exct she brilliant you watch her
you go God she's brilliant like I watch
her man one of my best moments ever is
when she saw me at JFL and she saw the
set she goes that was really funny and I
was like this woman is on another level
I just watched her man I was like origal
it was the coolest thing ever and she's
very remember we hung with her in she
was awesome but uh yeah there is I mean
that that was what they used to tell you
like you hand out the business cards oh
yeah oh yeah like Kevin Hart is both you
know but that's rare Dane Cook dude I I
knew a guy who had these cards super
hilarious that was his thing he was
super hilarious at gmail or whatever and
he would go here you go here you go
those guys if if you say super hilar
it's like saying I'm hot and I know it
you're like you're 900 lb you know it's
never a hot girl with I'm a hot and I
know it it's always over compensation
every time and then you get these guys
you read their card it says director
producer writer actor comedian M I'm
like what is this V you're I I to hand
me a card he goes feel it you can't
possibly rip it I'm like if that's a
thing you paid extra for maybe don't
invest in the business card there's
nothing really you know there's nothing
worse than a guy who's been doing it
like seven months who's a full business
person you know what I mean cuz we all
hated that guy oh yeah we were all like
just get
pizza sign up at the pit Michelle wolf
will put you up there you go try to kill
for two minutes and get and shut up
that's the job don't like tell everyone
your strategy so here's the question
we're talking about delusion and all
this and who's funny who's that who's
happier the delusional weirdo or like
the
delusional you think I don't know
ignorance is bliss they're much happier
but I think when it kicks in when
they're 40 they just eat a gun or eat a
bullet there's I I know this one guy
this one guy from Long Island right he
did like song parodies this is the
funniest
he's been a rightwing guy forever right
he's has nothing ever going on in the
business ever he's doing a Facebook live
one one of my favorite things I've ever
seen he goes like this he goes I'm
waiting until there's 100 people in here
before I uh before I I I got got I got a
big announcement he goes I got a big
announcement I'm going to say it I don't
care oh no he gets like 50 people he
goes we'll go with
this so if 50 people get in he goes he
goes I'm in Hollywood now he's standing
in front of his house in like sville
Long Island yeah snow covering it he's
got like an old car on the driveway he
goes I'm in a business where it will
hurt me to say what I'm going to say and
I don't care he goes I'm supporting
Donald Trump he goes I don't care if I
never work again this is a guy who does
song parodies in Long Island bars every
not one person thought he was doing
anything but supported he's like and it
hurts me the busy he goes I don't care
if I work he goes I don't give a he
goes I'm going to hear from people in
Hollywood that this is not good for my
career but he goes I'm supporting Trump
and it's just like is he happy that's
what I'm asking and he might be he seems
stressed to make that announcement yeah
he might be or he might be stressed but
then I think he gets in his car and he
goes I don't give a yeah I'm Lenny
Bruce I don't care about anything I told
him I'm supporting Trump well there's
the flip side of that of the girl who's
like racism is evil you're like all
right we we're in Brooklyn we all agree
with you you're not a hero no one's even
racists don't think they're racist right
the the KKK are just like we're a
community we just we're doing the right
thing we're preserving tradition yes yes
exactly or say with the the God hates
or whatever those people think
they're saving the world right no I've
seen the I mean I used to do a bit about
the racism SHP like no one is on no
one is against you no you're not you're
not strong here's what's interesting
about that you rare like that type of
Comedy when you think you'll see it you
almost rarely see it a lot of the people
who do it on Twitter all day when they
get on stage they just do very hockey
like yeah jokes like they don't
it's not like what you'd think it would
be like you'd think they would get up
there and do some like try to but then a
lot of it's just very like old school
kind of Happ yeah you go just oh this is
that I look like if this guy that
guy and but all day on Twitter it's it's
politics it's like at mayor Adams do
something right right you see actually
like oh whoopy could you imagine cuz
there was about a year when those those
racism as bad as was they were
everywhere there was a year when that
was hot it fizzled oh my God how many of
those you'd be in like Burlington
Vermont they're like we support black
lives in this store and I'm like I feel
like all stores support black people
yeah that's a law that was made in
well a couple of Clan bars in Long
Island a little suspect on that there
might be a bar or two in well there's a
Chinese there's a Chinese restaurant
that I go to in uh when they if the
black people walk in the woman goes you
pay now to go like it seems a bit
hostile they don't have the bumper
sticker there H I'm doing take out I pay
out online she's like pay
again but my point is that don't be a
menace that group that did all that that
racism is bad whatever you know imagine
them at a a Uso show right could you
imagine these people are in Iraq
they're getting shot at and this is the
comedy they
see gay people should be allowed to get
married you're like you're in uh you're
in SoHo you're in a bar show not a lot
of resistance tonight right yeah yeah it
is funny it is funny but they'll also go
it'll be funny if it swings the other
way they'll swing with it sure so that's
what's fun like what's fun about them is
like they will just swing with it I know
they'll go they'll swing with it yeah
they'll start doing hey are we woke
maybe we're a little too woke like
they'll go from I'm woke till we're a
little too like it'll just it's all a
pendulum but they never go back and go
sorry I yelled at you but being I did
find those song parody guys so
funny when I they were funny he's a
funny guy I remember remember there was
a guy I forgot his name but he had
a song we go I hit a girl and I liked it
I like you should have seen that pop dud
the biggest one of the biggest comics in
Australia this guy who they told me
about in Australia who sounds like a
legend this guy did a song parody of
Meredith Brook song uh and and he
called it so I bring verer out on stage
on the road that song for real oh really
yeah bloke you know the no no well it's
a song parody of by Meredith
Brooks it was so big it was like they
were doing it in stadiums in Australia
I'm a bloke I'm an auger and I really
like your
knockers and he does his whole thing
this guy's like such a legend he killed
someone on his wedding day no that's
what a legend he is he's a comic he's in
a bar he gets into a fight he ends up
killing a guy and has to do six years he
kills a guy on his wedding day he comes
out of prison and he's doing
comedy he's a legendary comic he's like
really funny he's and he does this song
called bloke Chris Franklin and and it's
like actually killed him by punching him
yeah a few times I killed a guy and I
lik it but this is play play a little
bit of this cuz this is actually a funny
song parody I tell you something he
killed that tune oh yeah how many views
is that I don't know but he uh he's a Le
well well this was back in the day and
they show up to like he did it he did it
in like the AFL Stadium or something in
Melbourne like this mass of like 80,000
people wow and the whole audience is
singing it all and they they're all
going I'm a blow you know so it's like
Australia is a really interesting place
you're there and you're like I love it
and then there's moments where you go is
everyone like I just you don't
know it's interesting I messaged you
about it recently I told you you're
going to like it I have every restaurant
you should go to if you're in a zoo you
feel too you're like I'm I'm on the
other side of the world no one can get
to me yeah it's kind of interesting and
then I did are you doing New Zealand I'm
not okay cuz it's more detached because
you go then you four hours to Auckland
New Zealand then you're in New Zealand
and then four hours on a plane south of
that is Antarctica wow it's over you're
the furthest in the South Pacific you
can go yeah and then is Antarctica so
there's you know I love it like I always
go like I've gone now twice and I go I'm
never doing it again every time I do the
flight and then I just always go back
it's fun it's one of those things where
it's like I really like it when I'm
there and I love the comics like Nick
Cody's great Luke from La sucks I mean
I'm going from New York I'm
dreading that I mean that's that's
by the way that's inhuman how are you
are you're laying over in LA or
something yeah yeah or SF put a day are
you doing it all one day no just get it
over with just get it over that's what I
did just I'll pop a muscle relax for the
second one I I'll knock out you got
movies you got food well so what's
interesting is I stayed up like a whole
day I go in she's like she's like we can
serve you the food whenever I go I'm
just going to conch out so I ConEd out I
wake up and I'm like I've been
asleep 6 hours I'm like that's great I I
walk up to her I go that's really good
I've never slept six hours on a plane
she goes yeah she goes we're doing good
she goes we only got like nine hours
left oh my God so then you're like oh
this is and then you look at where
you're over and it's like the Mariana
Trench you're not over anything you're
like I hope the plane's working I know
you feel lost those flights over the
Pacific you're like I really hope
everything's in working order that's
when you need that guy from oh C on and
we hit
turul like I need a dad right now and we
hit turbulence in them and you're like
it's and you're in the but they're just
like it's normal it always happens and
you're in a Boeing Triple 7 which is a
beautiful plane oh it's the best you can
get stunning I did a new I did Auckland
and it was the wildest crowd I've ever
had they're great they're great it was
awesome but they threw drugs on stage I
do a Q&A at the end they yelled out
where I was like I'm offended you know
it's crazy it's it's um
it's it's it's it's it's like it's the
end of the world yes you're at the end
of the world it's they call it it's an
island of volcanoes right I mean they
were all just sitting there waiting for
the big one so it's kind of amazing and
there beautiful Parts like the nature
there unreal the ring Lord of the Ring
Jurassic Park but then the like I stayed
by the casino yeah because you know what
it is it's it's a certain type of person
that you like there's a native in their
blood yeah there's they have some and
it's like they have a sing
and it's like it's something weird
starts to happen with the booze and like
their Mulla abling like the back of
their neck and the way they're it's like
it's like a different kind of bird
you're like this is like a weird it's a
weird group it's a weird group but you
I'm I'm into it they're very different
even though they look it's similar in a
way but it's off there was a show called
Sliders in the 90s I remember that Jerry
o time travel and Sliders was and Louis
kind of talks about Australia like this
too where you you're there and you're
like it's almost our world right and
then Louis says oh like a weird power
they fly by so the sliders was just they
kept trying to get back to their world
and every time they'd slide into another
diens some of them would obviously not
be theirs like it would be like
dinosaurs but then some of them you'd be
like oh this is our world and then it's
like somebody's like head would like do
a full 360 you go oh we're not I wow
slider what a bull you're always talking
about
food this is my recommendation by the
way I'm supposed to have a
recomendation slers watch what do you
watch true I don't even know you feel
like a documentary guy uh well sometimes
but I love I love I love D I love really
crap stuff selling Sunset I'll watch
selling Sun the whole season so hot I
I'll watch it uh to the two midgets
right the thing but no but uh I like I
I'll watch like Santa Clarita diet we
like drewry Drew Berry Moore is like a
zombie I'll also watch the great things
the wires The Sopranos that you know
that the house of cards first couple of
Seasons but like blood Line's good on
Netflix you know Netflix original that's
a good with with uh Ben uh Ben Mendelson
who's great oh he good he one of the
best actors and bloodline is really
really good that's a if you haven't
watched bloodline on Netflix it's slow
but it's good space at Kyle
Chandler Ben Menon uh Linda Cardellini
it's a really good show it and I love
Florida so to me I could kind of just
watch a show about I do kind of love
Florida too Florida fun me for how often
I gig there is there anything better
than after Side Splitters a nice rain
like a nice right you got Heming way on
this I kind of love Tampa crowds though
Tampa I love the food in Tampa it's just
like coconut shrimp and it's nuts it's
fun yeah some of the best sets of my
life are probably a it's amazing cuz
they're they're kind of down the middle
and you can't offend them there's
nothing you can say that'll so you so
you'll go harder and then you just it's
like the best set you have I had to
think I was just to riff about like
great Club the mo how many like pay by
the hour motels that are around there oh
and and and I was like my friend's
really like she's from Tampa she's
trying to defend it she goes yeah well a
lot of people like are going to Bush
Gardens so that's where they stay I go
that's not what what do what kind of
family is staying in a pay by the hour
Motel to go to Bush G I mean it's like
so Tampa has like a seedy dark
underbelly which I've always liked been
there my party there for that reason
always respected that yeah area eore
City chickens running around in the
street yes I love that stuff great time
I think it's good it feels like where
you would be a boat like Pi Miami to me
I love Miami but Miami is very much like
it's like Global and sexy and the crowds
are not good but uh Tampa you're like
this is designed for comedy yes designed
for comedy There's real people there
there's real people there yeah Miami's a
Lauderdale great crowds it's like it's
something about Florida yeah Orlando's
great crowds they all they all Florida's
good man Miami Improv can be fun too
they can get a little wild
but 30 minutes late and on coke they are
late and they they don't pay
attention they're like they're not like
working people they're like influencers
and yes exactly it's Latino La
basically yeah it's interesting so
la yeah good point it's La there there
we go Jacksonville too like s Augustine
all that they're all pretty good they're
great they're great yeah they're fun
people it's hurricanes it's Jews it's
old people it's Cubans Florida is like
the weird soul of our country in a way
it's we need it even though it is crazy
you ever go to Key West no I've never
been there
Florida I have I got to I want it's
worth doing just you get on a jet ski
you wake up you live like a pi everyone
there is drunk everyone's ran over a kid
in ' 89 they they fleed to Key West you
know no one in Key West is not running
away everyone is it's all running they
all think they're Jimmy Buffet they're
all sunbaked and brown and R by the way
no one who lives like that regrets it no
no there's no you'll never meet a guy in
Florida who's living that life who's
like man I wish I was in Chicago no no
one on a boat in Florida wants to be
anywhere else you got that right good
movie wreck by the way I bet you've seen
it uh kargo
Bogart and uh Edward G Robinson and
Lauren McCall great flick really
from the yeah Florida does bring out the
worst parts of you so when you if you
ever live there you go to or or or even
spend a like a lot of time there you
just got to be ready to confront that
yeah you know because it will bring up
out the part of you the the Primal
Darkness
yes blow off a guy's ass you know you'll
be doing something nights there for sure
oh yeah florid baby the the late night
drink and yeah I definitely I was at the
Don CeSar which a great Hotel in St Pete
Beach and they were all getting ready
for the hurricane there's this guy
outside drunk and he just looked at me
he like guy he's like Let It
Come you know so that's kind of what it
is he goes let it come it's like
Lieutenant Dan on the boat come on all
you got it's like that's you just got to
you know it's it's it's fatalism down
there you're like this is it oh yeah if
I end up in the mangrove
that's what happens yeah that's what
it's a weird combination of paradise but
the world might end yes but it's people
that go there to die so you have that
energy too it's people that are like
I've given up or I know I'm in the final
stage and I just want to be me right I
want to be me like I have a friend who
moved down there and she is um you know
insane now fully insane she's not old
but she's like middle-aged and she's
went down there and the thing about
Florida is you start acting years older
than you are when you start living there
it's weird so if you go down there in
you're like 40s you start you you start
acting like you're a
retiree and she's just you know she's a
lot of fun but she was me and Big Jay
are really good friends with this person
and we love her because she's one of the
funniest people in the world I think I
know who you're talking about crazy
Michelle yeah yeah so crazy Michelle
said the funniest thing we've ever heard
she sat me in Big Jay down years ago in
Chone W Hollywood she looked at both of
us and said without any hint of Arney
she goes I feel horrible for Harvey
Weinstein
wow it was the best she goes I've lived
here 20 years these they lie and
me and Jay laughed so hard I put up a
picture of Jeffrey Epstein on my story
once she just had no idea who he was and
she just responded
gorgeous so that's how out of it she is
and she's down there in Florida and we
we still love her I gu removed from all
the
allegations yeah she was gorgeous but
she's just down there in Florida um you
know living that that Florida life
gorgeous she goes gorgeous yeah she go
gorgeous wow but she the king of Florida
yeah she's down there in Florida now
just kind of like she hangs out with
like a nun oh she has one of her best
friends is like a nun and I'll call her
and she's like yeah I'm at the nun's
house it just gets wild yeah it's weird
it's she rides around on a golf cart all
day you know she's married to a comedian
we
know you know I sat next to him on the
FL ones nice nice as guy very sweet very
sweet I'm curious now after all right
all right we got to get down to Florida
I'm going to Tampa in January I'm going
Florida December I got I got Fort Meers
and Tampa and then you got St Pete right
there and it's beautiful oh it's great
Scientology is over there clear water
everything's nice I did a club called
balushi once and it was one of those
like hell gigs where I bombed every show
and it's so Florida that the bartender
at the end of the weekend just goes kid
you deserve better and I was like oh my
God and it was one of those gigs where
they just wouldn't pay me it was I was
like you know I have like a 6 a.m.
flight and they're just waiting around
for like they're like we'll get you and
I'm like it's 2 a.m. please every
bartender in Florida has seen the
darkest things imaginable like they
could be 22 they've seen everything they
have the face of like a weathered
divorce you know they just they're like
yeah we've seen things in this bar that
you can't even imagine you know Myrtle
Beach has a little stank on it too so
does Virginia Beach I don't know if you
ever been there but uh both are pretty
terrible Virginia Beach scared of that I
just feel like people have like like
penis
hats parties there was a club in Myrtle
Beach called uh what was the name
of that club was it just Carolina Comedy
Club yes that was it oh my God I
remember it was the worst weekend ever I
I I can't it was like every table was
drinking Long Island Iced Tea I've never
seen in my life just trays of long some
like some of those Beach communities are
fun like dead crow is
great that's a whole different game
that's a nicer Vibe and remember the guy
there used to be like a conspiracy
Museum there yes yeah it was cool but
that's what they film like Iron Man
there wilmingon is a nice really cool
yeah I had sex with the owner of that
club good guy
Timmy a lovely gentleman a sad Beach
town like AC that's is sad AC I like AC
but it's Vegas with AIDS yeah you can't
really walk out there anymore you can't
even the seagulls kind of look like they
have AIDS there yes it's rough
everything's dingy no one's
attic city is no one there is up to
anything good no no youed to get a I had
to get a prescription filled there once
if you it's The Walking Dead you want to
talk about you want to talk about Mike
Lawrence's bachelor party me Scott
choplin Sean Donley Mike Lawrence yeah
in uh the uh what was it the to the one
that closed down the showboat or
something like the one that was like
clown themed and it was I mean it was
just tough that what why would he do it
there and reine I think was there uh I
don't know he just wanted to see
Atlantic City you know Mark Mike was
like Darkly poetic of course you know
like of course we were talking about
Mike the other day he's kind of a
savant brilliant yeah he's really a
funny what about off the hook I
know that you're not a I hate it that
was the worst weekend I've never done it
I haven't either I had a horrible time
there it was one of those weekends where
they just would I couldn't rip Eric
Myers who was opening for me that
weekend he great guy oh my about how bad
the weekend
was he uh he was bearing me too I mean
he was like high energy and a lot of his
jokes were like young people suck and
I'm like I'm not going to be able to
follow them I mean it was murdering I
mean murdering is as much you could do
it with hilarious guy I remember going
up yeah he was really he was very funny
and and a very nice guy and oh my God
was I bombing it was like it was one of
those gigs where you were like all right
well I'm just going to play The
Greatest Hits it these are all my
best jokes I've ever written the most
broad jokes these all worked on late
night these all you know and I'm still
bombing it's like it's one of the things
where like I can't you just feel like
you're drowning the whole set and I
remember wishing death on multiple old
men uh it it was horrible and they just
don't it wasn't it's tough and then
you're
like Naples is not ideal for comedy no
they're you know what was great
though was the Palm Beach Improv yeah
West they closed they
closed it's I know it's a great night
one of the greatest gigs for me cuz I
think Palm Beach is great and you just
go to the beach and everybody's insanely
rich but in a fun crazy we they're all
trumpies and they're all driving pink
rolls-royces you know and they're like
nuts and it's fun I love that
gig that we go Pure Vita every meal
amazing Fu great I had a I had a show
there once the guy in the front row he
had a table of like 12 twinks and he had
that what was that uh Versace all
Versace and he's like another bottle of
champagne and they were pouring it in
his mouth and he's like dance I'm
like I'm trying to do my bit about
cereal but he was just he ran the whole
show he like he was the mayor no it's
CRA you've got people there we had like
we had a table of just
old drunk like body women oh like those
type of ladies who were like you better
be
funny like where did they come from like
hell opened up and they just emerged a
far side it's fun because all you need
to do is on them once and they're
like great that's what they came they
came to get called a or something
quick that's what they came we got the
Real Housewives of St Pete they're like
right you got that right that's right
right exactly you know yeah those are
those are those are fun though those are
fun they fun they're the best gigs I
love those other than Naples I would say
I kind of do love every gig in Florida
Florida's amazing it's a good Escape too
you get why people move there from New
York all the snowbirds I don't know if
that b Club is still around look it up
it's still around hard is what Arizona
could be but it isn't there's no water
there's no ocean you need an ocean you
need the ocean because the Arizona The
Stand Up live I love it's one of my
favorite clubs but just Arizona when
you're driving around and everything
like that you're like they they become
lizard like the people they're like kind
of sunbaked brain like they're open
carry yeah so Florida you just it's it's
a little nice still there yeah holy
it was
rough I wonder how much he knows about
the club who balushi oh his business
manager calls him every now and then and
goes well yeah why are they naming it
after a guy that's so weird I probably
sells tickets I like hey we got you ever
do
acroos an acon we got aroids over
here have you done G Brad Garretts have
you done any of like the named after a
comedian Club I did the Kimble I popped
it on the Kimmel Club one so that's
that's pretty good in Vegas Garrett is a
famously decent one he I I hear a great
guy yeah he's probably a great guy I've
never been there I've never seen any of
those what a horrible idea to open a
comedy club as a as a funny guy yeah
that seems you got to do inventory and
deal with you know I was here watching
Joe do it was interesting because like
oh he was able to good point he's a
zillionaire yeah cuz he had the money to
do it exactly the way he wanted and
andly and he goes up there and he goes
up there and it's such a better like
it's amazing instead of being on the
road forever his family it's like oh I
have a club I can go do work it's really
cool it's kind of a secret weapon he's
doing two hour a night on a Tuesday in
front of a full full house I got to get
I got to get there you haven't been
there I every weekend they they offer me
every week they offer me I'm booked till
I tape I'm like I'll do weekdays but
they're like it's just you go it's just
a scen a casino in the back everybody's
sitting having like an Italian dinner
and like the back you come in everyone
looks like ah okay New York gu it's
about time it's about time I want to I
want to do it but yeah where are you
going to be what do you I know you're
prob you got Carnegie Hall tomorrow
that's tomorrow yeah what in December
this comes December right oh oh wow nice
I love the I have to do a topical thing
so I can't ever get ahead oh I yeah I
can't bank I have to do topical uh
December go I go scroll down I have no
idea yeah uh December Detroit Toronto uh
the mothership Columbus Bethlehem and
Washington DC Ohio San Antonio Dallas
Atlanta St Louis Indianapolis and Boston
Foxwoods AC round it out rounding it out
AC with no material I don't know what
I'm going to do it's like something will
happen in the world something will
happen in the world I heard you were
doing the
Apollo yeah well I'm waiting I'm going
come back we're not doing that it's not
right I miss I miss some of those dudes
where is he I don't know he's around all
right what do you got there I just got
uh yeah Tampa as I said Fort Meyers
Buffalo
Springfield uhal Madison Philly Dana
Beach Omaha Dallas OKC Irvine Salt Lake
City when you're an Irvine we'll hang
out let me know because no one ever
comes to La anymore I I'll be there and
uh yeah and then I'm taping in in Boston
that'll I'll drive down to irvan cuz
it's not that far that'd be great yeah
let's hang please there's some good
restaurants down there it's fun you can
have fun there yeah yeah I love that
room it's funny when you drive to Irvine
that Orange County there's a line where
the roads get better there's plants
everywhere the buildings are prettier uh
all right hey what do we got here Crest
in Sacramento we added the show Omaha
Kansas City Northfolk Baltimore
Birmingham
shreport Tampa Jacksonville coming to
Florida baby Columbus Indianapolis New
York New York at the Beacon uh Houston
San Antonio Texas Salt Lake Markman
comedy.com check it out get some Bodega
cat listen to Tim's podcast it's
hilarious one of our faves this was I
was really happy when IUD thank you for
having me yeah thanks for doing it and
uh Winnie's still kicking pissy Elliot
she still kicking man and she how old is
she 16 that's she's very
sweet thanks a lot folks good night that
was F good that was a good
[Music]
one and's talking and I get
down in the same
way up on the roof like a cop coming and
naked Samuel is feeling
dangerous I'm out to lunch here in New
Orleans this woman doesn't look like I
remember and I get down in
the we
might
be
true